Nintendo have been promising news on a
new experience for switch and it is
definitely not what you thought it was
gonna be I'm just and this is your
cardboard rific GS news update
Nintendo have revealed what looks like a
minigame collection called a Nintendo
lab basically it involves creating
real-life cardboard accessories that
come with the game yep Nintendo is
making crafting in real life cool again
Nintendo released a trailer that shows
the player fishing playing piano erasing
a bike and wrecking [ __ ] as a giant
robot by popping the joy cones in little
cardboard contraptions that form what
they're calling toy cons maybe it's the
hyper bright background music that
accompanies the trailer or the purring
Kitty noise every 10 seconds at the
beginning but it does look like a
genuinely great idea and so very
nintendo it appears that along with your
cardboard you'll get instructions for
building each toy con contraption on the
screen and by you I mean the kids who
this game is designed for and by the
kids who this game is designed for I
really mean you 2 separate bundles have
been announced so far the $70 variety
kit and the $80 robot kit both will be
available on April 20th in the US and
April 27th in Europe the official
website for labor suggests you can
customize your creations by painting
them or affixing stickers aligned on the
site reads dream up new ways to use your
toy con creations and bring them to life
we're not entirely sure if that means
there will be more ways to use the items
in the game or whether it's just a fancy
way of saying use your imagination my
money's on the latter you can currently
apply to try out labo ahead of its
release in New York or SF so long as you
have a child who is 6 to 12 years old
always a catch for more news on this one
as it unravels keep it tuned to games
but
[Music]